à saint-arsène près de rivière-du-loup
jonathan roy est en pleine récolte son
petit jardin est un laboratoire c'est
ici qu'on fait pousser la majorité des
plantes qu'on va utiliser dans nos
différents spiritueux à la distillerie
fils du roi
c'est ce qui va donner la personnalité à
nos différents produits en fait le
dernier né de la distillerie fils du roi
et ce pastis la grande hermine
ici on va faire la culture de la gaston
et la plante qu'on voit tout près ici en
arrière on voit le carvi le carvi 5 ou
légèrement à nice et un peu mentale et
puis
il y en a à peu près un an quand ce
qu'on a décidé de fabriquer une recette
de pastis le service était un élément
tout désigné pour nous le carvi est
l'ingrédient inattendue de ce pastis du
bas saint laurent à la grande valse et
le riz car c'est la référence mondiale
c'est du sucre de l'eau de l'alcool et
de l'année ses toiles et ce qui fait un
grand pastis selon moi ça va être après
l'utilisation de différentes épices de
macération qu'on va utiliser soit en
macération soit en situation où le mieux
selon moi ça va être vraiment une
méthode combiné jonathan a fait quelques
entorses à la recette du pastis de
marseille et avait quelques petits
points qui nous faisaient sourciller un
peu dans le cahier des charges du pastis
de marseille on peut ajouter du sucre on
peut acheter du colorant on peut ajouter
des saveurs artificielles ont été
chercher des aromates qui se porte bien
un pigment ici donc le lagaf' tâche qui
est un goût à nice est aussi plus
botanique plus + herbacée légèrement
poivré et on a ajouté le carvi qui ont
aussi un goy nice et mais plus côté
mental et et se passe ici n'utilisent
aucun sucre aucune forme de sucre aucune
saveur artificielle uniquement des
plantes qu'on veut faire macérer dans
nos alambic traditionnel l'anis étoilé
est l'ingrédient de base de tout pastis
jonathan ajoute aussi de l'anis vert du
fenouil de lagaf' tâche de la réglisse
du quart vie et de la vanille moi c'est
vraiment ça qui m'a happé à la première
gorgée
on utilise la vanne est entre autres et
le carvi pour donner cette impression là
de sucre et ça fait donc un produit qui
vous coupent l'ucla beaucoup plus
rafraîchissant beaucoup plus facile à
boire à mon goût
le ce qui doit être très très très
timide il faut vraiment qu'on semble
tout d'abord la rondeur de l'anis et
cette année cela doit être sublimées par
l'utilisation de d'aromates ce pastis se
déguste nature bout avec un peu d'eau
pour plus de rondeur de 3,5 pardo selon
l'intensité désirer la grande hermine
sert aussi à confectionner des cocktails
le pastis en fait ce bois excessivement
bien avec le cérou votre choix
ça peut être un sirop d'agrumes ça peut
être un sirop de menthe
ça peut être la grenadine et très
populaire également mes coups de coeur
personnel c'est vraiment avec de
l'oranje du tank de l'eau pétillante ça
peut être super intéressant mon bon ami
pascal en fait une version en bleu dit
césar qui est absolument fantastique
l'anis et la tomate et une demie grandes
découvertes de l'année
c'est vraiment fabuleux donc je vous
dirai si vous aimez le goût et que vous
êtes un fan de bleu du césar enlever la
vodka
mettez du pastis à la place vous ne
serez pas déçus et au fait pourquoi la
grande hermine
j'ai été voir un historien qui m'a parlé
des des bateaux qui partaient de de
l'europe pour venir ici mais ted du sort
des roches dans le fond de leur cale de
bateau et en traversant ici rendu dans
le bas saint laurent y aider au fond
donc jeté lilly rush et le ca par dessus
bord ce qui a amené énormément de
semences tout le long du fleuve saint
laurent qui vient directement de
l'europe donc c'était premiers arrivants
l'eau sont rôle sans trop le savoir ils
y ont amené beaucoup de d'aromates le
carvi peut faire partie de son c'est
pour ça qu'on a nommé notre bassiste la
grande hermine qui le nom du deuxième
bateau de jacques cartier quand ce qui a
traversé l'atlantique
[Musique]
une bouteille de grande hermine coûte 50
dollars à la sec